what's up reject nation we missed this
trailer yesterday so we're bringing it
to you today
netflix released a trailer for ratchet
based on nurse ratchet from one floor
over the cuckoo's nest
wow that's a cool shirt greg
wow that's a great transition john
thanks
we are partnering up with loot crate
but this time it's loot right horror
base loot crate
items you know your favorite loot crate
stuff but spooky so they sent over some
items to us
that we unboxed we got this cool
twilight zone
cookbook thingamajig show them some
photos
john for your recipes they sent us this
pennywise
pencil case what's inside
yeah i also got this shirt in case you
guys didn't get to tell what the whole
point of that was
the jaws uh metal print i'm excited to
partner up with them
if you use our special code in the
description box you get 15
off your loot fright subscription box or
any other loot crate for that matter
but i would go with luke fry i would go
with lewd fright and then for the month
of august if you order before august
15th they have items that are inspired
by the texas chainsaw massacre the lost
boys and a clockwork orange
that's the diamond slash box so get a
box today
and i hope we get that box too you
better yeah loot
come on and thank you yeah that one
[Music]
may i ask why you're head to lucia
it seems like a rather personal question
well i'm sorry ma'am didn't mean to make
you uncomfortable
i didn't say you made me uncomfortable i
said the question was personal
sorry this feels like a bates motel
thing
hmm your fingernails are filthy
poor guy
[Music]
i've always wanted an origin story of
the course
[Music]
save a hundred lives well then you're a
nurse
how
[Music]
just show you mercy
how different i would be if someone had
this looks pretty freaking cool man
[Applause]
oh wow there's gonna be some sticks
[Music]
excuse me you're eating my peach i don't
see a man
who would do that do what put their name
on a peach
somebody who really wanted it no one has
ever put their name on the page i've
seen it
no you haven't what are you gonna do
about it what are you dead
no just thinking of all the things i'm
going to do about it
that's what's driving
[Music]
getting me into this hospital was the
best decision you ever made
what a journey happy birthday to you
ryan murphy my goodness this uh
feels kind of like a mixture of
the ryan murphy aesthetic tone
and whimsy like especially what we've
seen with hollywood
and even glee for that matter and uh
some american horror story but even a
hint of like kubrick
oh yeah in there you know like there was
stuff that reminded me straight
out of the shining and and you know it
probably has a lot to do with
where the show takes place and the kind
of patience you're dealing with
i haven't seen all of american horror
story but from like the six or seven
seasons i've seen my favorite has still
been asylum
and so to see sarah paulson in the
league louise fletcher
she won the oscar for plane nurse
ratchet for one floor of the cuckoo's
so you got to get an actress who can
match that level of
determination intimidation striking fear
into the hearts of individuals i think
sarah paulson can pull it off oh she can
do that ice cold thing yeah i think she
can do it man
i think it looks good i think it looks
really cool i feel like you can get
really psychologically twisted very
demented
horror-based scenes throughout i think
this could be a special thing and people
liked hollywood so i feel like so far
for the netflix
ryan murphy feels like a guy that can be
really easy to hate for some reason
yeah very specific taste and if you like
it you like it if you don't you don't
i like ryan murphy i didn't like him a
lot and yet i i kind of get worried to
engage in conversation about ryan murphy
well you know he's a little famous for
dangling plot threads and trying to do
too much even if you do like his stuff
i just love how out there he is yeah
yeah yeah and i mean this is a perfect
vehicle for those
instincts at least for him as a producer
because i know he's not like the
original creator who wrote the
original idea up for this but it does
definitely have a sensibility and part
of me is like
once he started doing period pieces i
almost feel like he's like i really
gotta make the most out of these sets so
let's get a whole bunch of period
shows in here um but that said i mean
the production values and the aesthetics
look gorgeous
and it looks cool to have kind of both
sides you know because she's a nurse
obviously but you're also doing these
huge viewing gallery like lobotomy
scenes and stuff like that that reminded
me of shows like the nick or things that
are very much
based in older more antiquated forms of
medicine and
surgery and my hope for this i guess is
that it will
use all those pulpy elements and stuff
like that but tell a story that has some
commentary on mental health and
self-heldness and stuff
instead of because this is a slippery
slope in the sense that there's a lot
you can do to just make
mental health struggles
but at the same time if i know ryan
murphy i mean there's an exploitationy
side of him where it's like yeah there's
pulp for days but
he also seems like he wants to
communicate some kind of allegory or
message or something
so i got my fingers crossed this is like
the last character i'd expect to get an
origin tale
yeah and the thing to me that's
interesting is that watching this i
don't know
because of what one flew over the
cuckoo's nest is i don't think i would
be sitting there going
when are we going to get to the overlap
with jack nicholson yeah
it's like there's nothing really to
build up to and so in a way
i'm sitting here thinking okay well
maybe this could sort of exist on its
own because she
is the most distinct figure in that
movie aside from him well what i think
is exciting about
doing this show in particular because
it's going to definitely be horror-based
it's going to be out there it's going to
be fun but it's also going to be a lot
of horror
is that won't flow with the cuckoo's
nest it's not a scary movie but nurse
ratchet is scary so to do a show about
her
and have her undertones and
psychologically twisted things
throughout
from her perspective i actually i'm on
board for a spin-off like that
i haven't seen all of bates motel i've
only seen the first season
and a half i think i was pleasantly
surprised by like actually this is
not a bad show but when i heard the
concept of bates motel
yeah like oh so stupid why you know and
what can we do to
pad this out and expand yeah i was like
how silly how unnecessary and then
i'm gonna go out there and say this is a
necessary thing to do but i actually
like the conceit of it and what they're
pitching
on style cast and production design i
think it's gonna this could be a really
cool show
yeah i'm more drawn to this in the
hollywood one yeah in a lot of ways and
maybe it is because it's just got that
dark
nasty edge and also sarah paulson is
definitely the sun that appears to be
anchoring the entire gravity of this
show and it's really hard to
look away from that i think there's
going to be a lot of very gruesome
scenes
especially with the way like back then
with it with
insane asylums which i know was an
offensive term
but back then uh you know when they
would go and dissect the brain and try
to figure out what's wrong with people
like
they didn't really take the best safety
precautions and
you know that ryan murphy's uh if he if
he's involved in any
any amount and if it's gonna be on
netflix they're gonna go
full hardcore with the with the gore and
the disturbing imagery
maybe they'll just you know reuse some
of the old asylum
pieces yeah just bring them back what i
would like to know a little bit more
about
is what they're really gonna do with
making her a
character and somebody who's the center
the lead yeah like what's what's her
character journey
i imagine kind of like a paul thomas
anderson obsessive-like character
like a daniel plainview in a way of if
you can really explore the why
behind who ratchet is why she does what
she does and what her
driving motivation is to be this person
because i don't think you need like a
character
oh we need to make her really likeable
yeah but if you can make her somebody
who we don't necessarily
like who we're kind of horrified by but
we very much understand
and are fascinated by that yeah exactly
that could work
sarah paulson can sell that oh yeah she
totally can have you seen him
not unbreakable glass yep yeah
that's the one i saw glass yeah we all
saw glass we all song
i feel like sarah paulson gets a lot of
crap too does she
yeah i don't know why i think she's an
amazing actress
burn evan peters hold down american
horror story dude it's because she was
singing imagine that one time you know
oh is she part of that
i think maybe to hell with her i don't
know but yeah i mean like she's
one of the most consistent like
character actresses working today and
she's able to get
these kinds of lead roles but also
character roles which is kind of tricky
i mean it seems like she's kind of got
her own lane or a lane that she's
helping to widen out and she could do a
lot of different genres
oh yeah mainly horror horror and
things that are harsh all right guys
well what did you think of
this trailer are you excited for ratchet
leave your thoughts down below you think
it'll be worth your time
maybe what else do we got to do promote
loot frights of course get your real 15
15 off link in the description box promo
code all that stuff i like the way you
say things
john i do too all right guys hey
why don't we do a picture
anisa oliva on instagram anisa messaged
me
this video and i was like oh i guess i
gotta cover it because anisa's asking
for it and if anyone's
on the path to becoming a nurse ratchet
it's definitely a nissa
i mean she already works on an er yeah
she's already
witnessing humanity slowly crumbling
and letting that crumble her humanity
exactly
soon she's going to be totally immune to
the pains
of those who suffer so anissa when you
start doing some experimental treatments
on certain individuals of the hospital
you make sure to hit me up on instagram
with some photos and videos because i'm
going to want to report you
i'm going to want to call the cops on
you and i'm going to need to show them
the evidence
of the horrible things you're doing you
sexy
devil oh and if you could just write me
out like a detailed list of each thing
you plan to
do to whom when so we get that intense
establishment oh you've got that you
kinky for a little individual free
meditation oh my gosh
we're gonna have so much evidence on you
look out
put you away you're you're a pervert
criminal you
you're a murdering psychopath
please don't lobotomize us
we love you catch you next time